Hello and welcome to Monthly Mailbag where
we answer science questions
that you, our wonderful audience, send in.
Sometimes we tackle the mysteries of the universe,
and sometimes we talk about blind birds.
But this time we're sticking a little bit
closer to home.
I've been particularly excited for this episode,
because it combines some of my favourite things:
physics, mysteries, and showers.
This month we are answering Twitter follower
David's question:
"Why does the shower curtain billow inwards
when you turn on the shower?"
It's a great question, David. For those lucky
enough to have glass showers,
who may be unfamiliar with this effect, let's
take a little field trip.
Welcome to my shower.
The phenomenon is pretty simple.
You turn on the shower and the shower curtain
kind of attacks you.
Let's see it in action.
Wooh, that's some nice billowing there.
It works best with a powerful stream pointed
downwards.
The simplest explanation is that there's a
chimney effect going on.
That the hot air from the shower is rising
up over the top of the curtain
and the cold air in the rest of the room is
sort of coming in from the bottom,
pushing this curtain inwards.
But that can't be right because the water
behind me is actually cold water,
it's how we can get such a powerful stream
by turning both the hot and cold on full blast.
The next explanation is that it's because
of something called the Bernoulli principle.
Which states that fast moving fluids, liquids
or gases,
have lower pressure than slow moving ones.
When a fluid speeds up, its pressure lowers.
The fast moving water coming out of the shower
head pulls the air around it
making it move quickly as well.
This fast air has low pressure which sucks
the shower curtain in like a vacuum.
Bernoulli definitely has something to do with
it but it's not the whole picture.
If it was a simple Bernoulli situation, you'd
expect the current
to get pulled in all along the length of the
water flow, but it doesn't.
It's only the bottom that billows.
In 2001 an American engineer named David Schmidt
wanted to get to the bottom of it.
So he enlisted the help of some software.
He simulated a simplified scenario,
without heat, without evaporation or a person
in the shower.
And he found something surprising. A vortex
formed above the spray.
The centre of the vortex, much like the eye
of a storm
has lower pressure than the rest of the shower.
And it's this vertical vortex that's responsible
for the billowing.
Dr Schmidt won the Ig Nobel Prize, an award
given for
"achievements that at first make people laugh
and then make people think",
for this partial solution in 2001.
But that's nearly 17 years ago now
and I figured computer simulations have come
a long way since then.
So I enlisted the help of engineer Dr Dominic
Flynn at Birmingham City University.
He drew up a model of the shower in CAD and
he fired up the modern version
of the software used up by David Schmidt in
2001.
And he ran some simulations.
You can see in this little animation here
the see through box is the shower area.
The solid coloured curtain is the shower curtain.
The water is coming from the circle in the
top right.
Warmer colours represent higher water speeds.
And the colours in the shower curtain represent
displacement,
how far the shower curtain has moved.
So let's play this simulation.
We can play it again and you can see the movement
at the bottom there.
So we found the same results. Maybe it's helpful
now if you look at the cross section.
It's not the most stable situation in the
world,
but you can see there's definitely a circular
vortex forming.
One big difference between Dominic's simulations
and Dr Schmidt's simulations
is that Dominic's vortices were quite a bit
lower.
But our shower head was also pointed straight
down in this simulation.
Our simulation is a little bit more complete,
it has heat, but still no person or evaporation
so were still one step closer but we can't
say we have a full solution.
So let's return to David's question:
"Why does the shower curtain billow inwards
when you turn on the shower?".
Shower curtains billow inwards because of
Bernoulli's principle
but not in a straightforward way.
The fast moving air of a swirling vortex has
low pressure, which pulls the curtain inwards.
The bottom of the curtain is the part that
moves
because of another key principle of engineering
- the principle of moments.
The part of the lever that moves the most
with a given force
is the part furthest from the pivot point.
And the pivot here is the curtain rod way
up at the top.
Although it is a flexible material so it gets
a bit more complicated than that.
Now that we know what's going on here are
a few tips that can interfere with the effect.
The pull isn't very strong so you can make
the shower curtain harder to move
by sewing magnets or weights into the bottom.
Or you can get a curtain made out of a heavier
material.
A curved curtain rod can also interfere with
the effect
by encouraging the bottom of the curtain to
stick to the tub.
This episode wouldn't have been possible without
the generous time and effort
given by Dominic Flynn, a fantastic engineer
who helped us out with these lovely simulations.
I also want to give a shoutout to Dr David
Schmidt who kindly answered
what must have been the millionth email
about a silly project he did almost two decades
ago.
And this was actually my last episode of Monthly
Mailbag.
I'll be leaving the Ri and heading back to
Canada so I have
a few other special shoutouts to do before
I go.
I'd like to thank Cassie, Liina and Ed who
decided
it was a good idea to put me in front of a
camera.
To Ant for taking these videos to the next
level.
And to Sarah and Anand for letting me run
with it.
And really to the whole Ri team for being
so supportive.
And finally, thanks to you, the viewers and
subscribers.
You make all of this possible and worthwhile.
If you want to keep in touch, I'm on Twitter
@farrowjon. See you around.
That reminds me, I think I left the shower
on at home